this is my response to any requests to
wear a mask if you want me to wear a
mask this is what I'm wearing hello and
welcome to trigonometry I'm Frances
Foster I'm Constance I'm Kissin this is
the show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
and our brilliant returning guest is
Peter Hitchens the author and journalist
Peter welcome back to the show woods so
far it's okay to say we've never had a
guest interrupt us meet intro but you've
managed so let's get straight into it
one of the reasons that we were really
keen to have you back on the show is
that you have done a lot of alternative
coverage shall we say of the lockdown
and the coronavirus situation so for
anyone who has not been following your
writing and opinions on this issue just
give us a brief overview of what is your
opinion of what's happened and the
lockdown measures that have been
implemented okay right from the start I
said that the response to the government
was completely out of proportion to the
size of the Menace I didn't say there
was no disease and that say nobody would
die and say it wasn't horrible for a lot
of people if they got it but I said that
as an advantage certainly didn't justify
the measures being taken either to
suppress Liberty or to suppress the
economy I think that the damage to both
human liberty and to the economy have
been huge and probably permanent and I
think we will look back on this if we
ever have a chance to do so with it with
an impartial inquiry and say how on
earth did we go mad to this extent it
simply wasn't justified and it still
isn't justified and until the government
admits it made a major mistake we're
never gonna get out of it Eaton you say
the damage has been permanent I mean the
economy surely will recover will it not
well I don't know whether it will I mean
remember that we were on the verge of a
major slump as this began and remember
that the British economy is not actually
in a very good state despite all these
boasts about it being six biggest in the
world in fact in in in
real and more important terms of GDP and
so forth it's much lower down the scale
and fully the the level of wages for
many people has been falling the the
standards of living for many people have
been stagnant sometime and our ability
to recover because we no longer
manufacture very much is pretty thin and
just at a time when China is beginning
really to take off it it never looked
good for us and we've now contracted a
debt enormous size bigger than anything
ever done in peacetime before and now
wartime debts are terrible and they do
cause a great deal of trouble but they
are it was justified by the fact that
you're fighting for national survival
peacetime debts are just as terrible and
take just as long to pay off and do just
as much damage but you have to ask
yourself whether this was justified I
think part of the problem is that people
living in this kind of dream time than
that with the beautiful weather the
following which means people get paid
for not working that huge numbers of
professionals in the southeast who are
spared from the daily grind commuting
and so far have continued to be all the
work from home the will come a moment of
awakening where many of those people
find they don't have any jobs or if they
do then much worse pay than they were
before and that an economy based
incredibly heavily on services
particularly shops and restaurants and
bars will have suffered enormously for
months and months during which people
couldn't actually make a living and they
can't and it would be a key feature of
economics is not just the existence of
money but the speed in which it
circulates and if your salary isn't paid
or if the rent that you're owed isn't
paid for a quarter of the year then the
damage it does to your personal economy
into the national quality is huge
and people say it'll be a v-shaped
recession we'll leave out of it well I
hope they're right but I have a strong
feeling that they may be over optimistic
about that and Peter what do you say
about the argument there's lots of
people who say look we need to protect
our most vulnerable we've got you know
an ageing population there's lots of
people who've got you know health issues
what we're doing is we're protecting the
most vulnerable people in society and
you can't put a price on people's lives
points about that one we've been
extremely bad at protecting the most
vulnerable people in society
specifically those in care homes who in
fact by accident rather than by design
but certainly beyond doubt have been
exposed far far more than they should
have been to the virus and who are
probably now the largest number of those
people die from it they always were the
most vulnerable and I think there was a
strong reason to suppose this from the
beginning and they certainly had proved
to be so if that's what we said we were
doing we failed to do it in practice the
other thing is was this were these it's
already well saying that's what you want
to do but you're suffering from
something must be done syndrome here I
look at something it's terrible you say
something must be done someone comes
along with a mad set of ideas you say
well this is something we'll do that the
ideas which we adopted for combating it
had very little to do with the problem
the last thing you need to do is to put
patients from hospitals into care homes
where this appears to be what we did and
it it was catastrophic super to
quarantine the healthy is also an
unprecedented action and quarantine the
sick is a long long procedure going back
for centuries and it's perfectly
sensible the coronating the healthiest
is extraordinary think of time and again
it's a question of proportion and then
there is the third point which is how
many people have died or otherwise
suffered or will die otherwise suffer as
a result of these methods and the the
healthy old have suffered hugely in
terms of being deprived of normal life
and as a brilliant man professor suture
inductee of the university of mainz in
germany warned at the beginning of this
and I did what I could to publicize this
morning it is precisely those people
their healthy old and active in society
who've suffered very very greatly from
this by being cut off from social
contact and the amount of misery which
of course brings on death there of
course is the effect which I think
everybody not knowledge it's on the rest
of the health service while the health
service is concentrating entirely on
coping all kinds of things particularly
the detection and treatment of major
cancers is put to one side and I think
there will be when this is examined of a
fair number of excess
deaths which have resulted from this
this this policy which have not been
coded death so not even been remotely
related to coded which are among people
who who were deprived the treatments and
checks the otherwise would have got
because of the panic so sure we're all
concerned
I completely concede that my opponents
in this argument are concerned with
saving human life and their motives are
good will actually sir my but I think
not really on my motives go but I think
my assessments in this situation is
better than theirs and I think if my
policy much more closely aligned to what
Sweden has done had been followed a
fewer people would have died in both
cases those interesting paradox in the
middle of this Sweden made exactly the
same mistake with care homes that we did
and said catastrophic numbers of deaths
and caroms and they're still getting
them for that reason and so oddly enough
it's by no means can my name is be
advanced as a perfect example of how
things should have been done but it's
quite a good example of how things
should not have been done it simply did
not shut down the economy it did not
trespass on people's personal liberty in
the way that we have done here and what
would you say because Sweden are very
much the anomaly Peter if you look at
practically every other Western country
they've all followed our model why do
you think Sweden adopted the correct
tactic well I don't know it's it's why
in the old story of the Emperor's New
Clothes there's only one person who will
openly admit that the Emperor is naked
and that's the little boy now in real
life as we know if that happened the the
little boy would be cutted off by the
secret police his parents mistake
propaganda organs would all say that the
Emperor's clothes are absolutely
magnificent but the point of the story
is of course is of course otherwise
Peter I'm not trying to cut you off just
I just I want to focus on the stuff
about the shutting down of contrary
opinions a little bit later but just and
we will get to that to call Sweden the
outlier when Sweden's policy was
actually the most rational and governed
probably by the most qualified people in
the world
is straight and also we're very
Eurocentric when we look at this we
don't look particularly in Japan which
is just more or less come out of the
whole thing with fewer than a thousand
deaths in a in a country of 126 odd
million in several mega cities which is
also not followed the the extreme
procedures which we have done and Taiwan
is similar they've not done that either
and they've come out reasonably well
it's simply as impossible to say that
Sweden is the only country which is not
followed the policies that we have opt
but let me take you back all the way to
the beginning because it strikes me that
one of the big difficulties for the
government in this country in terms of
not imposing a lockdown was actually the
PR perspective overall if they had
failed to introduce a lockdown which by
that point the public seemingly were
clamoring for I think they would be
crucified and I think that probably
plays a huge part in in their decision
don't you think well it may well be but
it's government's job to be crucified
sometimes for doing the right thing it's
interesting to note that the government
and we can counter this as well if you
want in its defense of Dominic Cummings
as being prepared to take quite a lot of
crucifixion and and in my view oddly
enough that I don't like Dominic
Cummings I don't approve of the policies
that he that he has it was a reasonable
thing for us to stand up against this
but it shows that governments can if
they wish to do so stand up to public
opinion I think a lot of the public
opinion in this case was created by
government in the first place I think
some of the advice to save suggested was
a desire from States just as there was a
desire to create a level of fear which
is actually often quite easy to do
especially with invisible threats such
as a virus
the difficulty is having created fear
it's much much harder to dispel it so
what would you have done Peter the the
the threat supposedly is coming people
are well you say he was created by
government but some people are clamoring
for lockdown
lots of other countries are introducing
a lockdown and you you would just you
would not have one at all you would the
word is repulsive the word is a
refers to the disciplinary action taken
in American parrot entries against
rising convicts and with a free country
of free people I think in use the very
useful word that was an acceptance of a
lower more servile state of life than
the one that I personally have grown up
with in which to defend so I won't use
it except in inverted commas what I
would have done is more or less what I
did that is to say I stood out against
this from the earliest point at which I
began to write about and I said I had
serious doubts about what was being
proposed and that we were getting it out
of proportion and I can demonstrate and
I can tell you that this was not
pleasant at the initial response am I
saying this was an awful lot of derision
and Wurst and I thought I couldn't care
less the fact is it looks to me as if
we're making a grave mistake and we
should stand out against it and I felt
that it was very important for the
future of the country that those who did
feel this way should stand up for it now
so it wouldn't later on be classified as
hindsight and reflecting anything the
time I found that there were quite a
substantial minority it was a minority
of people who felt the same way I did
this perfectly possible to stand out if
it's possible for me a scribbler on a
newspaper to stand out against away from
public opinion and surely it's possible
for her most his government will
resources its command when the huge
Authority given to it by the fact that
has a mandate from the electorate to
stand out against it to say yes of
course I would a lot of the a lot of the
really important decisions in life has
to do with not doing things i say like
mikhail kutuzov pretty much defeated
Napoleon by not engaging him in battle
over Moscow and almost anybody who knows
anything about military tactics knows
what the crucial thing to do when you're
being charged is not to respond until
the last minute you have to not do
things a lot of the time and not doing
something was important on this occasion
certainly it's much much harder than the
Swedes have made this part to get out of
a shutdown at the economy in society it
is to get into it and this is the great
danger Britain now faces and who knows
how long of shuffling around in muzzles
and standing at 7 feet away from each
other making us all commerce and
pleasure and everything else impossible
or if not impossible immensely in
community
expensive in a way which will [ __ ]
the country not least it's education
systems has been dealt a terrible blow
but I feel so much for all those
students whose finals here this is and
for all those school pupils who's a
little users but their lives have been
completely blighted by this and I'll
never get back what they've lost and for
what Peter what do you say to those
people who say look this is a deadly
virus you know it has real health
complications that we that we don't know
the long-term effects of and we need to
lock down in order to prevent another
inevitable deaths and this is the only
way to stop people died well I'm always
very suspicious to people who say that
their way is the only way this is the
old Margaret Thatcher slogan there is no
alternative whenever anybody says that
you know there is an alternative and
they're trying to direct you away from
it of course there's not so yes it is
deadly to some people no it is not
deadly to all people and all the
information we now have suggest in the
Maine I know there are exceptions but in
the main it is much more dangerous to
those who are old and I said I mean old
seriously old and those who have a
number of quite dangerous
life-threatening conditions already so
it makes perfect sense for measures to
be taken to protect them but it doesn't
make perfect sense to close down your
whole society nor if you're concerned
about your ability to look after the
population through a state-run National
Health Service does it make sense to
destroy your economy and ravage your tax
base so that the years to come you won't
be able to afford even the much
criticized health service you have
already let alone a better one everybody
says they want so none of that makes
sense it's a non sequitur
if what you want is to protect people
then you need to be specific about it
wild general flailing propagandists
actions will not get you anywhere if you
want to react to a crisis you react to
an in detail in ways which makes sense
and this is what we did not do and what
we are not doing and where'd he stand on
because Imperial College have come out
for a lot of criticism for the modeling
that they have done I think at one point
they said that if nothing was done and
no action was taken I think the number
that was quoted was half a million dead
where do you stand on this do you think
they wildly overreacted or was that
their assessment of the situation well I
recently published a piece which out
which I first published on March the
22nd I think in the mail Sunday in which
I noted at the time the many criticisms
that have been made of past advice given
by Imperial codes particularly on the
the foot-and-mouth epidemic which I wish
I was something of a personal witness
nearly 20 years ago now and quoting
people as saying that it was not
necessarily to be relied upon I thought
at this I'm sure that Professor Focus
and his colleagues at Imperial College
are motivated by it by unselfish desire
to help others and by genuine belief in
their own and their own scientific
method but the fact is they're not the
only epidemiologists on the blog and
there were others notably Sinatra group
tour of Oxford University who very early
on suggested alternative ideas and I
think that the responsibility of
government is to choose between
scientists when they differ and I think
the government didn't try hard enough to
establish that there were also if they
also didn't didn't look at the very
important views expressed by both secret
bhakti who I mentioned earlier of nines
or of of of John Ioannidis of Stanford
University who said that the levels of
mortality which were being proposed by
the Imperial model were absurd and has
been I think vindicated by such a mid
events there were plenty of expert views
available it wasn't just a columnist for
The Mail on Sunday sales there were
plenty of expert Musa failable which
conflicted with the ones which the
government chose to accept I said I
don't doubt the sincerity or indeed the
competence of the people who whose
advice
I was taken and doesn't seem to me to
turn out to be right it's very difficult
to predict things and I'm not going to
engage in personal attacks on
individuals who would undoubtedly doing
their best the responsibility of gun was
to work out whether they were looking at
the right advice I'm not it's my view
that they took the wrong advice and also
they didn't try hard enough I had to
seek for advice different from that
which they had pretty much already
decided to follow do you think that I
mean this idea for
besides do you think that's just a
shield that the government decided to
hide behind instead of making difficult
decisions
I think it's an expression which which
betrays a misunderstanding of science
I'm not anyway scientists and I'm
obviously from the art side everything
but I know enough to know about
scientific method and how it works and
it's no it doesn't require enormous
amount of expertise to understand what
the scientific method is and other
things about scientific method is that
it involves constant disputation every
every conclusion which has been reached
by one generation is open to demolition
by another generation and their science
is actually about dispute there is no
such thing as these science right as
Plan C so is an argument in progress and
so to stand behind it as a shield has
been to use scientists a human field for
your policy failures seems to me to be
wrong so I just don't take that
responsibility they don't come along to
go and say look I am right you must do
this nothing general maybe some but in
general what they said this is what we
believe to be the case and you you must
act as you see fit as a result of it and
to say that the thing is settled and
there was never any argument isn't in my
view an invasion and responsibility by
the political class hello guys and
welcome back to my bedroom a que la
maison del bonking now we've got a
returning sponsor for you which is the
shaving company Harry's and I've got to
be honest to you I love harry's actually
using myself they give a lovely tight
finish to the skin beautiful light
razors they don't tug at the skin so
I'll give you a little bit of a
backstory about Harry's right which is
it's it's akin to stall is a story of
biblical proportions there were two men
Jeff and Andy now they may sound like
they're in witness protection but
they're not all right and Jeff and Andy
got sick of being ripped off day in and
day out like razor blade companies not
for being their end of the bargain so
they did what any regular person would
do they bought the factory the great
thing about Harry's is that the troll
said they provide you live gives
everything you need for a beautiful show
B gives you away
genomic handle a five blade razor with a
lubricating strip and a trimmer blade
although if you like me you won't need
the lubrication no I mean Gary and you
also get a lovely lathering shave gel
plus a travel plate cover for when you
need to go about you need to look sharp
day-to-day and we're really happy to
trigonometry to be able to offer you
this in conjunction with Harry's so you
get a troll set through a pound 95 that
is a trial shaving set for three pound
95 and the brilliant thing about this
offer is that it gets delivered straight
to your door so you get the shaving
handle the five blade razor the shave
gel and the travel break cover and it's
really simple to claim on this exclusive
offer all you need to do is go to
harrys.com forward slash trigger
harrys.com forward slash trigger to
climb your exclusive offer and who knows
if you play your cards right you'd end
up looking like me well that's exactly
it because what I saw with Eddy just I
mean it was obviously not possible that
the science was only one way there was
where there were gonna be scientists and
doctors who saw a different way but it
seemed like politicians and many
countries essentially abrogated their
responsibility for making decisions
based on this I think that the political
class in most modern countries is
extremely immature and ill-educated and
unfit for its task because politics has
become a branch of show business and
which ambitious young people rise very
rapidly to the top on the basis of the
ability to entertain sorry Peter carry
on as I miss that I said not the way I
do unfortunately Peter doesn't bear
repeating not actually very entertaining
not even any good at that I mean I just
look on the current one has many
criticisms of political classes you know
wages and more times but when I was in
my teens and twenties at least one knew
for instance that the people who were
governing the country it had serious
experience I figured such as tennis
helium even bean beachmaster at Anzio
he'd seen people
died beside it and Ted Heath on on the
other side likewise had fought in the
war people had seen great events and
understood the importance of what they
were doing I don't think I can think of
anybody in modern politics who has
anything remotely resembling that much
experience of life or that much wisdom
to draw upon these are teenagers and
they panicked
and do you think and I think this is a
Christian that has been leveled against
Johnson but I think it's a particularly
relevant criticism so for example if you
take Margaret Thatcher where do you
agree whether you disagree with Thatcher
you cannot doubt that the woman had
vision she had a vision of what she
wanted Britain to be all right yes but
you look at Johnson you I don't see a
leader with vision I don't see it's it
is it's very amusing company and you can
be entertaining to look at but again I
just driving idea I agree with you and I
think that one of the things that's
happened is that those who are driven by
ideas and beliefs the writers of books
the thinkers of think of deep things are
blind eyes pushed to the margin by the
say the show business and gossip aspect
to politics which makes such people
attractive if I view if you don't look
good on TV then who cares that you know
a lot you have a lot of experience you
won't rice and shop in one posix it's
really fascinating point you make and I
think maybe our obsession with youth is
probably part of that as well kita but
you know we used to talk about the big
beasts of politics I'm not sure I'm not
sure there's any beasts level disease
they're all small feral creatures each
other's tails there are no big beasts
and pizza so we've talked about you know
the the other the other people the other
epidemiologists the other virologists
who put forward a different case which
case do you think was the most
persuasive and the most scientifically
valid was there one particular one
qualified to say that what I can say is
what we have seen since this happened
has tended to show that the Imperial
model was mistaken but I think you might
it was much harder to say there's
obviously the beginning that's possible
but I think that the what there was
there was a great jumping to conclusions
and people wanted to do something big
and it here is the real the real
difficulties and what has happened here
why have we become in the course of
really three months I'm much much more
regimented country much for much much
more government fields with the police
telling us to do things and say we
previously had the nerve to what
happened here I think that there is an
enthusiasm in the modern state for
expanding its powers and I think they
saw in the the Imperial College modeling
an opportunity to do so I think for many
years just facing in the midst of a like
a cuckoo in the nest has been a has been
a a strong state and I think this is its
opportunity to gain a great deal of
extra strength which I think it's going
to be very very unwilling to give up and
talking about the misuse of power and
strength PT and kind of moving on to the
other part of this conversation there
has been a lot of big text censorship
around this issue interviews with
prominent scientists some of whom you
mentioned being taken down from YouTube
sometimes they reinstate and sometimes
not do what do you make of the response
in terms of managing information that
has happened YouTube saying they take
down any unnethe orotate of content who
knows maybe this video will be taken
down simply because you who is there to
say once you once you set yourself up as
the person say then do you give yourself
an enormous by the power I think anybody
actually deserves to have and this is
one of the principal objections to
censorship and people say it's not
censorship it's not done by the
government but I would say there's not
much difference really is between
actions taken by a monopoly provider of
platforms so the actions taken by a
government and you don't
Carrie says not censorship well it looks
terribly like it and it has in my case
it's the same effect if you do that
you're saying this idea is too dangerous
should be allowed to circulate people
are not to be trusted to be able to work
out for themselves whether it's garbage
or dangerous or whatever it is and
you're giving yourself more power it
seems to me than any authority should
have in any free society
we all know about that free societies we
can look now at the People's Republic of
China which I think even the even the
most reluctant critics and now began to
can see this is a terrible despotic
Bruce James or like a that's one way of
running in society and it has its
efficient citizeness advantages which no
doubt appeal to some people but it
doesn't appeal to me and I think most of
what makes life good in the part of the
world in which we live is due to the
fact we aren't like that
so I think we have to look at anybody
who tends towards the Chinese model and
say well you what gives you who gave you
who died and made you King who gave you
the power to babe I this is isn't wrong
I'm glad that YouTube have won at least
one occasion known to me withdrawn from
doing so but I think there should be
more protest against it when it happens
and I think the youtubes should
reconsider very strongly its policy of
imagining that it has the right to
decide what people are allowed to see
who do they think they are and Peter
where do you stand on this argument so
let's take the example of David Icke
David Icke has done a number of
interviews some of the week I think one
was taken down and then five GMOs were
then burnt down where do you stand on
the argument that what we're in is an
exceptional time and as a result we need
to make sure that the public is not
exposed to ideas it may be dangerous
that could then lead to an outbreak of
hysteria five gmask burning etc I'm
always stuck I know in Britain we can't
have a First Amendment because we don't
because we have the sovereign partners
and therefore you cannot have a the
constitutional clause saying elephant
shall make no law but in general I think
the First Amendment is a good model for
free speech
and it has exceptions it's always said
Frances the incitement to crimes
straightforwardly wrong so anybody who
incites the burning down of five cheap
masks or anything of that kind is
plainly breaking the law against an
assignment and it's not it's not a free
speech issue but if they're not doing
that and if they're not inciting
departments and if they're not in their
classic girl cliche they're not shouting
fire in a crowded theater where there is
no fire then I think that's a different
matter and it's also there's a very
grave tendency to attempt guilt by
association shutdowns by saying what
you're saying will lead to deaths
because people will die unnecessarily
have come in 19 because you've argued
against measures which would save their
lives that kind of thing being advanced
against me for instance that is just
censorship dressed up Rousey
there has to be a straightforward line
there's a lot of jurisprudence on the
First Amendment and I always recommend
to anybody is this a fascinating book
called the shadow university about the
long battle to try and maintain some
sort of free speech on American campuses
during the rise of the speech code and
an awful lot of work has been done to
try and streamline and explain and make
clear the full effects the First
Amendment people if you read see where
these board is run but they do run and
they never ever prevent the free
expression of opinion or the free
expression of criticism of government as
such and to be honest you know I agree
with you Peter and what I'm really
worried about at the moment is is this
outbreak of hysteria and I think we've
seen it with Dominic with the Dominic
Cummings incident now I don't
particularly agree with what Cummings
did I thought you know I think it was
irresponsible and all the rest of it but
I think the reaction to it has been
really really worrying well we've just
seen members of the press either on
Twitter or wherever it may be
just behave as if you know that they're
losing their mind I think a lot of
people I think we have some recognizance
in all our dealings with everybody of
them I notice it after all
weeks of confinement at home and have
been deprived to normal regimes a lot of
people are on edge they're much they're
much ready to go off the rails and they
were people who do my wife especially
yes I will have to if you will have to
speak to you about that we are all a lot
of people are doing things which I think
when they look back on their behavior on
earth did I get into the state might I
think this is such an unnatural state of
life in which we find ourselves
when people are doing things they
wouldn't normally do and his massive
Syria but always a much bigger problem
than individual exterior is definitely
about I think the problem that johnny
counterfit mayor's say this I the first
time I met Dominic Cummings nearly 20
years ago I loathed him on sight
nothing I've ever heard of or seen since
has ever caused me to doubt or regret
that decision
I don't like him I don't like the
government he works for I'm not his
spokesman but I agree with you this has
been a ludicrous event and what the
things that he did were perfectly normal
actions which are not a matter for the
criminal or disapproval I also strongly
disapprove of the the network of
informants which we seem to have
developed in this country the people who
prepare to inform on their neighbors for
doing things which are not actually
illegal or in my view necessarily wrong
what's wrong in this country is the
imposition of some almost completely
insane rules of life which which
dominant coming didn't follow or two
points here one the reason why donut
comes should be in trouble of any kind
is quite simply that he demonstrated
that he himself didn't believe in the in
the rules which he was urging everybody
else to do on the government I don't
think governor the same same with
Professor folks and he was he was caught
being visited by his host I put it um
it's fair enough I try to be as polite
and as legit as possible here again if
he really believed the stuff that he was
saying how could he have done that here
we were he was a good looking woman he
was a if Tony comes really believe stuff
the government
Bobby how could he have done what he did
good enough so he didn't believe it but
there was a public ought to be angry
with the stupid rules and with the
stupid governments and posing them but
instead it was diverted into a scalp
hunt against the individual this is
become a feature of politics in recent
years and the media go along with it
because they can offer them win they get
a scalp at the end of it which makes
them look more powerful than they
actually are and governments get away
with it because they can toss somebody
off the sledge and what's the wolves ran
them to pieces while they carry on doing
what they were doing in the first place
so no real politics taking place I'm
against it really cause it's not it's
not about politics
it is amazing when there are people who
apparently submitted with that protest
it's a mass house arrest and to the
destruction of their livelihoods by the
government I prepared to get angry about
an individual who drives his family's
accustomed to bonod castle it seems to
me to be a failure in proportion on
grounds and do you think that Cummings
has served essentially as a lightning
rod for the disenchantment of the people
of the British public and where they
find themselves that's one reason why I
very much hope they keep him on my own
theory isn't the best thing to do with
joint counties is to make him attend all
the brief all the future government
briefings on Kovac my team only
prominently displayed but only wearing
one of those muscle things because if
such a good idea always always there to
remind everybody that while it drones on
about about testing and tracking
although I said the government doesn't
believe a word of what it's saying that
I believe would be an appropriate
punishment for don't counties but if
he's fired that he will be a lightning
rod will lightning conductor as I say
but if he's if he's if he's kept on and
they know he won't be because people
might begin to be angry with the
government rather than with Dominic
Cummings and angry with the rules rather
which is what I would like to see is
fascinating the kind of transformation
that has happened in our political
debate and our cultural space isn't it
because we now take moral guidance from
Piers Morgan and Alastair Campbell given
this their that when you look at the
Archbishop of Canterbury it's hardly
surprising that people are searching
elsewhere yeah
and constant in there touching on the
press might say I have to say getting
more guidance from Alastair Campbell is
well not something that I would
personally seek that's a very diplomatic
way of putting it all the people
involved you know that when someone is
given an honor long service and
government okay okay KGB or an MBE
whatever the people in the Iraq war
should have WMD permanently after their
name comes up on television should be
asked to Campbell WMD every time
tattooed into their foreheads if anybody
wants to take anything they say
seriously after that then that's their
look at hello guys and welcome to my
bedroom
aka dormitory oh they'll progress you
know now we've got one of our returning
sponsors coming back this week
essentially one of our favorites
favourite sponsors it is the wonderful
hello fresh and hello fresh a brilliant
because they delivered to your door
freshly prepared ingredients from
scratch which means that you can cook
and look like an absolute Pro and know
what you're doing even though you're
completely useless you get 21 recipes to
choose from from your family favorites
to balanced meals under 600 calories in
fact they're pretty good if you're
single and desperately trying to lose
weight in fact guys I was on a date last
night and I made the recipe which was
spicy sausages sticky Caribbean style
veg and mashed potato and I got to tell
you something the Caribbean star vote
was the only thing getting sticky that
night but doesn't matter we move on and
the reason I love hollow fresh is
because it's dead easy to use they
deliver straight to your door the meals
take only 20 minutes or less to cook so
when the ladies come round they think to
themselves well the chat was dreadful
but the food was great and actually
hello first we've got brilliant deal
coming up now where they're gonna offer
you 50% of your
spots and then 35% off your next three
boxes that's 50% of your first box and
35% of your next three boxes I mean that
is an absolute lovely deal if you want
to take advantage of this fantastic
offer which is exclusive to trigonometry
fans all you need to do is go to
www.hsn.com or next three boxes and guys
you're going to look like an absolute
professional in the kitchen basically
you're going to look like me and isn't
that what everyone wants so we taught in
constant and very touched on the press
with Piers Morgan how do you think the
British press have conducted themselves
in this national crisis reckon they've
covered in selves in glory or well no I
think the number of organs and and
television stations and really been
prepared to actually give a voice to
dissent has been too small and
nonetheless I here I am I have been able
to say
prominently what I have said for all
this time a lot of people have heard it
I've got my own newspaper but the the
very credible intervention of Mike
Graham on talk radio who disagrees with
me but it was each week allowed me a
weekly half-hour in which I dispute with
him the whole nature of the virus panic
even Piers Morgan a person I am and not
exactly made for each other but he did
at the beginning of this invite me onto
his program and of course he hadn't
given the nature of what are you saying
after day he had to give me a hard time
but the fact was there it was on on a
major television news and current
affairs program there was I able to put
the country case so all credit appears
on that so there it's not it's not
totally bad it just could have been a
heck of a lot better it's getting better
more and more people who didn't have all
that much courage to begin with finding
their courage to criticize this and more
and more people are realizing that it
may well have been a mistake but they're
gonna need to be an awful lot more if
we're to get out of it because as I say
the only way we will ever get out of it
is the government actually openly admits
which would be very good for them as
well as for us that it made a mistake
and that it overestimated the danger and
these precautions are absurd and won't
work and that's a save the country is
what what what remains of the country's
economy and to restore our lives they
simply have to accept that they do it
wrong only half I think there would be a
great deal of rejoicing in the public if
any government ever actually admitted to
make a mistake an investigation mistake
is so large that the opportunity is so
great that I do very very sincerely hope
something will happen forsaking rulers
and I suppose actually that's an issue
where the opposition wouldn't really be
able to make much hay out of it because
they're on record as having endorsed and
supported the lockdown as well so for
them to say that and I'm very much in
that camp veto I initially thought that
it was the right decision but I think on
reflection I do feel like it was an
overreaction destroyed themselves as a
parliament has discretion itself this is
this in the durian Custis the
Cromwellian period province had lots of
names like the bare-bones part of the
rampart and then whatever else was part
I think this Parliament should go down
in history either as the supine
Parliament or the plastic part it has
been so completely useless they have not
in any way on their rations there's been
hardly a voice of criticism there wasn't
even a vote over the passage of the
coronavirus Act and the Hamas is
opposition has never at any stage
opposed fundamentally the policy or
thought it was even its duty to examine
it the same to some extent must be said
of a lot of other areas of civil society
a lot of the media as I say the Academy
the civil service I think might have
been tougher in offering in offering
contrary advice I don't know where the
courts would be and I know that Simon
Dolan is
been trying for some time to get the
course to the bid but it's it's taken
him an awful lot of time to get not
anyway very fast in which when you
compare that with what happened to Jeana
Miller and with the the other great
Supreme Court case out of the peroneal
Parliament is the interesting contrast
whether you could see that the Supreme
Court in that case was itching to to get
involved now the court seemed to me to
state I've lost every one of the safety
device is built into our Constitution
against this kind of silly panic has
failed function it's the thing I'm
trying together is in terms of you
obviously think the lockdown was a
mistake right and I guess what I'm
asking is will we ever know because
we've had a lot of excess deaths the
question is have they come from the
coronavirus or have they come from the
impact of the lockdown and that effect
will continue as you say because if
people aren't attending cancer
screenings if cancer screenings are not
being done in the same quantity as they
were before
etc etc we will have this long-running
impact which anyone who wants to say the
lockdown was right will say well look
these excess deaths happened if we
hadn't locked down it would have been
worse and equally people in your side of
the argument would say well look at all
these deaths from the lockdown
that was a mistake even ever no I won't
just say that I would say that if the
government needs to establish or that
any of the actions that it took actually
saved a single life or reduced name any
real pressure on the National Health
Service remember the government is like
a druid by going to the villages of some
United village near a river and saying
look if you don't sacrifice your herd of
cows there's going to be a terrible
flood and they'll all drown
and so the verge is believing the Druids
as they do sacrifice their cattle
mournfully eat them and the river
doesn't fly on the dresser they see you
sacrificed your cattle that's been their
flat and how can anyone then prove that
it wasn't because the villagers
sacrificed their capital rule didn't
flood in a primitive society but in an
advanced society such as ours we can
have an infirmary you know but hold on
are you saying that the people
at least separate it doesn't doesn't
help are you saying that keeping people
physically separate doesn't prevent the
spread of the corona virus well I don't
see any reason I mean it's fascinating
facts and it's it hasn't had anything
like as much coverage as it should but
Governor Andrew Cuomo of New York state
commissioned a survey of those people
who've been hospitalized since he shut
down State for gorillas virus and 66
percent of those who've been
hospitalized stayed immediately at home
so you tell me we have we actually know
surprisingly little about the
transmission of this virus we also know
surprisingly little about where it
arrived so for instance there definitely
it's a case of Korean virus which is now
mean encountered in France in December
of 2019 and many people that I know
suspect that they had it long before the
panic began we're also now getting
information about its ability to spread
it seems suggested it may may not be
much about 20% so we don't know one
other thing I might point out to you and
I think this every time I see somebody
when I'm out on my bicycle
somebody veers 20 feet away to avoid
passing too close to me and they're
often wearing a muzzle as well it's
actually far easier to spread a virus
when you were in close contact with
somebody our house and when you're out
walking and so confining people to their
homes may actually that's pretty I don't
know here's here's the fact what is what
is it's clear that no one can
demonstrate that this mass confinement
to the population has actually treat
mentally the virus if you look at its
behavior although there are variations
in different parts of the world which
are quite possibly to do with wholly
different things follows are pretty
straightforward belk earth pattern it
begins it rises to peak it comes to an
end and there's very high levels any
human action has any has any effect on
that and I wait for anyone to provide
any and given if all they done was say
declared next to bank holiday or change
suit Amalia Stephen Hawking opening eyes
something of that kind then you wouldn't
mind too much these people have crashed
the economy it will advance country who
can find millions of people's of their
homes and prevented them from working
for weeks and they require much more
justification having done that than
anything that they can provide so far
the thing that I'm worried about Peter
and look of my worries itself which of
course they are because we're inherently
selfish however I can't see an end to
this I was thinking about this the other
day and I was thinking and you know
people are talking about a vaccine from
what I've read there's never been a
vaccine that has ever been created
against the coronavirus if you think
about the last great pandemic that we
have discussed that we've enjoyed is the
HIV AIDS virus there is still no vaccine
against hiv/aids and you think to
yourself well if that being the case how
are we gonna get out of this and what is
society gonna be like if we have this
inverted commas new normal well I
completely agree that's why I say the
government must admit it made a mistake
because this will this will never work
and we were talking earlier on about
excess deaths yes there are but there
are been previous occasions with excess
that's usually involving influenza and I
now have to say because it's if I don't
say it I will be slandered I have said
yes I know a corona virus is not
influenza okay I know it's not I'm not
saying that it is what I am saying is
that there have been previous outbreaks
of a disease which have had very similar
effects on excess deaths as an
interesting website will in proportion
which I urge people to study which makes
these comparisons making allowances for
the change in population and the two
occasions in recent years and one in
1968-69 and the famous as then was Hong
Kong flu or mild flu sometimes now where
the time is very problematic number
where did a number of the number of
excess deaths was either as great as
were in 68 69 considerably greater than
this is also interesting article I think
virus that came too late
pointing out that the main distinction
between growing virus and the other
previous epidemics and Scout is that it
comes later in the year but if it had
come in January March February it would
have seemed much less surprising most
Western European hospital systems are
used to these quite large outbreaks
quite frequently happening and they are
often not significantly greater than
what we've undergone so isn't as
exceptional as it's been made out to be
and the completely false equation of it
with the 1918 so-called Spanish
influenza which had nothing to do with
fangs
is is to be avoided that the 1918
outbreak killed the young and healthy in
terrifyingly large numbers and Kelvin 19
does not do that but you're right about
the difficulties of creating a
vaccination for a virus in this kind and
that one of the difficulties is a
decreasing number of people who can
actually be found in gossiped which is
causing researchers some some great
practical difficulties and a lesson
until we recognize that we we
overreacted to it then we are stuck with
these endless measures of track and
trace phones and scary messages from the
government and face muzzles and and
keeping children sitting miles apart
from each other in school and not be
able to go to the pub without plastic
screens dangling from the ceiling kinds
of useless expensive rubbish which will
make life unpleasant it will also
destroy Commerce and people say oh well
commerce who cares about that set
against life well eh you're not saving
lives and B the economy is what sustains
life if there's no economy where is the
money to come from for the food and for
the clean water and for the decent
housing which is the basis of good
health and where is it to come from for
them for the health service which we
claim to value so much we've devastated
our tax base so that the ability of this
country to pay for health services the
kind wants in the next in the years to
come is going to be greatly damaged by
this and people will suffer as a result
people really suffering anybody who's
trying to tries to do anything with the
Health Service at the moment knows that
it's not working vain
it's a deliberate working out before for
anything other than can be the thing
that's been a great dive motion and this
and that's for the madness of dentistry
you say that one of the worst pains in
the world comes with you if you have
serious teeth problems but you try if
you've got an emergency dental problem
getting anybody do anything about this
company goodness
it's being criminalized it's really
really important for the numbers of
people are suffering around the
government is just letting it go on and
on because they won't admit they made a
mistake
you think the health consequences are of
the way we've reacted are gonna run for
years and years I you can't tell exactly
how bad the damage is and the enormous
load which Maynard Keynes negotiated for
this country from the United States at
the end the Second World War when
lend-lease stopped was was negotiating I
think July of 1945 and wasn't paid off
until December 2006 my entire childhood
was spent in a country which was
constantly weighed down by the paying
off of and the paying of interest on
that enormously our lives were grayer
and more pinched and our public services
worse you look at look at things like
cancer house building in the early 50s
with a low standards of the architecture
in the building when the country was
poor and it was poor because it was in
debt and and but that was a debts
honorably contracted as a result of war
this is gay it's going to be poor
because of a debt contrasting because of
government mistake and Peter yeah I mean
it's a very very good point I mean we
interviewed comedian and expert on the
economy on the economy called Dominick
frisbee and he made the point he did a
book on the history of text which was
very interesting and he said that in
wartime every wartime there every
government uses it as an opportunity to
introduce new tax to raise taxes do you
think after this the government and
Ritchie soon after going to turn around
and go look
we furloughed a lot of you and he paid
your wages unfortunately now is
back time and we are going to be taxed
up to the hill in an effort to get you
know it's not an opportunity it's a it's
certainly true there was a must have
been some people who wanted a big estate
who were glad of the excuse more time to
make estate big secure than nineteen
fourteen to eighteen to begin with but
that but 39 to 45 as well
pretty soon up has no choice it is it is
really a question of how soon he has to
announce the emergency budget the first
I think of many emergency budgets which
he will have to introduce which I will
be one of the few people who will not be
shocked by and the these budgets will be
very serious and people who think that
it can all be loaded on the well off
very much mistaken the things we 82 C's
and all kinds of things digitally on
travel I wonder haven't people who long
to go back on holiday are going to feel
about how much more expensive it's kind
of beating on quite possibly there's
going to be something called the capital
levy a raid on the savings or every that
means amongst other things quite
possibly on the value of houses which
people have bought it's unprecedented
free country such as this which people
will find the security since its levied
on the savings they've made from already
tax money they'll find very oppressive
but the government will probably call it
something like an NHS surcharge you'll
be very hard to resist politically and I
doubt very much whether the Labour
opposition will resist it because they
will know there are only colonists no
but there is no choice the government is
going to have to increase tax the other
things as a country we are going to be
so much in debt and that the the levels
of interest which we are going to be
willing to pay to the pension funds and
the insurance covers which has loans so
much than those in government they're
going to be fantastically low that means
a raid on the pensions and savings of
millions of people whose old ages will
be on the threat that also happens and
the other thing is the world will look
at us and see an economy much weaker
than most and it may be less and less
willing to lend us money and
which we've been willing to do so and
there was also this nor certainly be a
decline in the international value of
the pound sterling so again that that
has many many effects from sticky on the
cost of imported goods and on our
ability to travel abroad which people
will feel there's going to be a lot of
things going on and it it wasn't going
to hurt and as I say this is a dream
time this long long period of sunny
weather during which chattering classes
and lays in their gardens drinking
glasses with missus
mister mystic glasses of Waitrose
Chablis thinking it's all going to be
great
it isn't they'll be lucky to be able to
afford the Chablis when this is over in
life well my guess it's going to be
really hot it can't be anything else no
one no guns ever spend this much money
in peace time with horrifying prophecy
there from Peter Hitchens the middle
classes we'll have to go with that sadly
is a terrifying prospect is it not we
will come in to the end of the interview
so we have one more question but before
I our question just summarized it in in
one word for us the lockdown has been
finished the sentence a catastrophe they
got one more question okay Peter and
obviously the last question that we
always finish our interviews with is
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be one thing yeah III
can't reduce it to one thing you knew
you're gonna ask me this and I think but
I can't do it because there are now
currently so many hmm I think I think we
really have to be more more realistic
about our position as a nation I think
we live in a world of illusion about how
important and how rich we are and I
think that this illusion was about to
come to a very very brutal end I think
we're going to have some worry
finally in a way that we haven't done
even since the Second World War and all
the other great events in the past
century we're gonna have to worry about
what sort of country is this how
important are we how rich are we what is
it what we really really are concerned
about becoming how can we how can we
cope with our diminished status what are
we going to have to give up we're
talking about this you've been talking
about this for some time PETA and
talking about our over estimation of
Britain's role in the world what what do
you think our approach should be how
should we see ourselves going forward I
think we should have an outbreak of
modesty I think a very good symbolic
action for us to take would be to
abandon the modernization of the Trident
nuclear weapons system I think we're
having spent all the blood and treasure
we have done on one becoming and you
keep anything we should give it up
entirely and keep a few bombs but for
old times sake but the the maintenance
of a vast Cold War superpower nuclear
weapon system is an absurdity given a
lack of wealth and importance it should
go and in the in the abandoning of it we
should recognize our change status and
begins to consider what we really want
to spend our wealth on and what sort of
country we were to be a big good it'll
be a good thing to do anyway a good
psychological moment and I say this is a
very pro defence a highly conservative
person who comes from a service family
so don't accuse me of being so kind
peace thing it's just something that has
to go so you have an embrace hippie
being a hippie in your later years Peter
then I'm sorry I said you haven't
embraced being a hippie in peace no it
doesn't appeal I've always either been a
reactionary
Theodora trotskyist and they both
actually centimeter we've market with
similar positions when when you strip
away the the externals but no the
Hippias will never appealed Peters thank
you so much for coming back on the show
everybody thank you for watching make
sure you go follow Peter on Twitter at
Clarke mykos all right it is yep
any of the explanation this curious
handle is to be found on Peter Hitchens
FA cues which really does exist and you
can do this fantastic well Peter thank
you so much for coming back and we'll
see you again soon our closure thank you
very much
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the Bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word